big news out of the supreme court there
is nothing standing in the way of new
york prosecutors getting former
president donald trump's
taxes for purposes of a criminal
investigation
recently the supreme court denied a stay
request from
trump basically this is the whole game
it's not about a decision on the merits
the trump camp wanted to prevent
the new york prosecutors from getting
his taxes while the supreme court was
figuring all this out and the supreme
court says no
we will not stay things things will go
forward and now the new york prosecutors
should be able to get access to former
president trump's taxes and that's a big
deal because mazar is the accounting
firm that was holding these records
has wanted to comply with prosecutors so
there's nothing that stops them from
handing those over to the prosecutors
immediately and that's continual bad
news for the trump camp because new york
prosecutors just signed up mark
pomerance who's a former federal
prosecutor who appears to be an expert
in these kind of white-collar
tax-related crimes
so let's see what happens and if you
were a member of the trump organization
i may actually see you in court